how are you doing today sir
i'm doing very well steve all things
considered how about you
i'm in the exact same boat um let me
start by saying how much i loved your
work
uh in this film and how much i loved the
film itself
uh this is just one of those special
movies that comes along once in a while
uh i am curious you've been lucky the
last number of years to do a lot of cool
things but ultimately
a script like this is so rare um how
much did you pay to be in it
[Applause]
oh um quite a bit i can't it's there's
an
nda attached to it so i can't tell you
the exact number but quite a bit
what i love also about this movie
besides the message and everything else
is that a younger generation are going
to be exposed to these four people from
a long time ago that
maybe they haven't heard of especially
sam what did it mean for you
to be portraying such a
gifted person and a gifted writer and
singer
uh it was just a tremendous
responsibility
uh a a horror show to begin with as you
can imagine you know it's just not
something those are those are
ill-fitting shoes to say the least but
um
uh a great responsibility and then
ultimately a great honor
uh and but i knew that i could obviously
i could lean
on the road map the beautiful
road map that kemp powers had given us
with this script we got regina king's
exceptional leadership and then
those three actors those three brothers
who i'm sure you will agree
i mean the work that that i was seeing
them do in the room
was endlessly inspiring so i could just
keep digging deep and
do my best to earn my my spot amongst
them
uh your rendition of exchange is going
to come is
so magnificent i'm curious what it meant
to you
to be singing that song and sort of how
did you get ready
to deliver that performance while
singing that song oh man
i'm grateful for the way this schedule
worked out because
i we that we shot that on my final day
in new orleans and i'm so grateful
because
um i
i found a lot of my sam in those
interrogation scenes in that hotel room
that that taught me who he was
fighting for something you you know what
i mean
i mean having to defend myself and and
having
kingsley as malcolm pushed me around a
bit and
you know questioned me it it made me
stronger
and so the day that we shot that
that scene i just sam was never closer
to me than he was on that day
uh and it completely shows on screen um
the movie takes place in 1964
but it's as relevant today as it was
back then
and i'm curious do you feel like
over the last year with all the things
that have happened with black lives
matter and just everything that's been
bubbling up do you feel like
like that maybe the country and the
world is on the precipice
of a change or do you still think it's
going to be um
you know decades of a fight and it's
still going to be a fight
all the time oh i i
i i am hopeful guy that's what gets me
out of bed i'm hopeful
and uh i i i believe that it's
it's closer than ever that's the kind of
guy than i am
enlightenment um an awakening
um yeah change is is
always available to us and um we have
another opportunity right now
to uh to to
draw closer to to the
our better angels and make the right
choices you know and and heal
old wounds you know but there's there's
ghosts
here in america you know talking about
the the history of native americans in
this country certainly the history of
slavery
in this country there's lot that we have
yet really to reckon with
and maybe we can do it once and for all
i don't know
one of the things that when i speak to a
lot of actors who are portraying a real
person
in a in a serious role like this a lot
of times uh people stay in character
even when they're you know all the time
just to or they keep a voice or they do
something to stay in that headspace
did you do that while playing sam at all
or were you able to just
sort of shut him off and turn yourself
back on no i
i do it for a time so i did it probably
for about three or four weeks
you know but that's intense it is it's
exhausting too
you know to to keep it all up in the
breaks and stuff
too um to keep up the dialect to keep up
that that pitch you know because sam's
voice was higher than mine it's it's
tiring
uh but it's necessary to really sort of
to lock it in
you want it locked in but by the by the
time we were done shooting i was able to
go
in and out but for the first few weeks
it is really it is helpful
to to stay in it uh i am a big fan of
central park
and uh i thought you did i thought you
did such a great job with that and i
love the songs i i'm really a huge fan
of the series
i know you're recording you're doing
season two right now yeah
what can you tease people about uh some
of the songs and
the the story i record it right here
right like literally right
this is where i record central park um
it's
just just i was saying to my wife the
other day i finished i think
episode i don't know maybe the third or
fourth episode of the second season and
i was just telling her
how much better it is my favorite
animated shows if you go back to
you know the long-running ones you go
back to the first season they're almost
unrecognizable it takes a while in
animation to really
find your thing to gel as a cast you're
recording all separately
it takes a while for the writers to hone
in on the character to hone in on your
strengths as an actor so
uh i'm pleasantly i'm just looking
forward to
you guys getting a glimpse at season two
because i think it's even better
love it i love hearing this listen i
already gotta go i'm just gonna say
congrats on everything
and thank you so much for your time and
being you know congrats on being part of
this movie
thanks brother be well